phân tích phổ điểm kiếp thí tốt nghiệp Trung Hoặc Phổ thông năm 2020, nhiều trưng ra dự báo điểm trình vào các trường
đại học thuộc nhóm top giữ sẽ giảm đáng kể sau với năm trước, đặc biệt ở các tổ học
sẽ tình trình thống như A không không, B không không, D không một, Tổ hợp B không không, Tổ hợp B không không, Tổ hợp B không không, Tổ an,
Hoa, Sinh, Khi nhận mức điểm Trung bình thấp mất trong nhiều năm trở lại đây. Chúng đó,
mô sinh học chỉ đã trung bình năm 1815, giảm khu phy năm 2020, năm 2020.
Điều này sẽ để khả năng sạm xấu điểm trình ở các ngành í, dược, điều dưỡng, bốn vụ thuộc lớn vào tổ hợp B không không.
Mô số trường dự kiến điểm trình có thể giảm tư một phy năm 2020, thậm xí thấp ở mức sản năm
ngoái, tư mưa chiến đến 20, 20, 20, tưng tự, tổ hợp A không không, bán, dí, hoa, và đe không một toán, bán, anh,
cũng có suy ứng sạm tư một đến 20, anh rửa chức tiếp đến các trường có mức tình trung bình và không thuộc nhóm này hóc.
Trong khi đó, các tổ hợp xa hội như xe không không, bán, dự, điện, giữ mức ồn định ít biến động về điểm trình.
Các trường đại học tóc đầu vẫn giữ ồn định của nguyện ít có thể đổi lớn.
Tuy nhiên, nhóm trường tóc giữa đăng bởi giá cơ hội lớn cho thi xin đặt bức điểm hát,
biểu đưa trình hưởng vận vụ hợp, kì thời sẽ giúp thi xin tăng cơ hội chúng tình trong bởi sát biến đại học năm nay.